Well our next speaker is Professor John Hirst John Hirst is a historian and scholar of America's tripe University.
He was founded convener of the astray and Republican movement in Victoria
and a member of the prime minister Keating's Republic advisory committee not in ninety three for the Howard Government
he was chair of the civics education group which oversaw the preparation of materials for the discovering democracy
program in schools. He has written books on convicts the origins of democracy a New South Wales.
Albert Facey Federation and the Republic. He was CO What it coeditor of The Oxford Companion to a strange history.
His most recent books a sense and not since in a strange history two thousand and six.
The Australians insiders
and outsiders on the national character since seventeen seventy which appeared in two thousand
and seven the shortest history of Europe two thousand
and nine which has been translated into I clanged which is at the strength history and seven questions.
Twenty four tane. He's going to be talking to us to die.
On the subject of British rights and liberties in Australia and I'd like you to welcome John Hirst thank you.
Thank you. British rights and liberties in a strike.
In nineteen fifty Robert Menzies angle of file excellence planned an attack on British rights and liberties.
To counter the threat of communism. He proposed that communists could be declared such by executive act.
The onus of proof was to be reversed. So that the clay and person had to prove they were not communists.
And the decision on whether they were Communists was not to be made by a jury.
The Libre position that under suspicion because of its connections to communists in the trade union movement had an
easy task in opposing Menzies they denounced the UN British of his measures
and trumpeted the principles of British justice. Dr Evatt SHADOW ATTORNEY GENERAL.
Declared that a bill of this character would never get a moment's consideration in the matter of parliaments at
Westminster. The Bill.
Nevertheless passed
but the measure was declared unconstitutional by the High Court Menzies then Hill a constitutional referendum to give
the Commonwealth the path to ban the Communist Party.
If it led the movement for the no vote in the literature prepared for the referendum campaign in the light the party
proclaimed that it stood for British justice and as the protector of Magna Carta and the rule of law.
Whatever Magna Carta is real position in a strike in law was at that time
and we're going to hear more about that later today.
It was still a potent symbol of British rights
and liberties it played a bit part in undoing of Menzies attempt to ban the Communist Party.
If it's
when in the no case was the high point of his career even though he had other claims to find as an historian jurist.
And as a founder of the United Nations as one of the founders
when he was a judge of the high court in the nine hundred thirty S. He published his most influential book.
The ram rebellion an account of the overthrow of govern apply in eighteen a light previously Blyde being regarded as a
tyrant. If it wanted to overturn that few.
And persuade his readers that the governor was using his powers properly to stamp out the monopoly of the military
offices in the trade in RUM
and so support the small farmers who were the victims of the offices stranglehold on the colony.
The introduction to the book began with the words used by John MacArthur the leader of the rebellion in writing to his
wife after the rebellion was excessively accomplished.
I have been deeply engaged all this day contending for the liberties of this unhappy colony
and I am happy to say I have succeeded beyond what I expected the tyrant is now no doubt gnashing his teeth with
vexation at his overthrow the purpose of ever spoke.
Was to show how folks in so those words were the introduction proceeded to castigate all the historians who had been
gulled by McCarthy if it was particularly separate on Roderick Flanagan.
Who had published his history of New South Wales in one thousand nine hundred sixty two Flanagan concluded that this
rebellion against Bligh. Had some similarity to the rebellion that gave in England Magna Carta or all of ends.
If Blodgett knock it did not occupy a position similar to that of King John MacArthur the officers
and their adherence occupied a situation similar to that of the barons on that interpretation.
If it heat or scorn at his command.
The battle between Bligh
and his opponents was fought out in the courts with the officers composed the juries if it used his legal skills to
support his thesis that vested economic interests success.
He defied the governor's Bly end his predecessors because they had the monopoly not only of wealth and violence
but also of justice the American scholar hotly gratin in his forward to the book drew out the full implication of
evidence arguments in Marxist tunes the officers women AAPL us
and die with the dominant class the law is a superstructure of society raised on economic foundations which inevitably
precipitate social struggles in the 1940's fifty's and sixty's
when Marxists interpretations were very strong in the academy.
Everts book was hugely influential Angus
and Robertson reprinted it six times I was introduced to it at the University of Adelaide in one hundred sixty two the
other thesis has since been demolished first by Roger Hines Worth who showed that the offices monopoly had long since
passed with the arrival of a Mensa posts
and free immigrants into the commercial world then by all of that concern who showed that there was why does my among
the townsfolk of Sydney at Bligh's determination to knock down houses
and make Sydney conform to govern the Philips plans for that guy the leaders of the rebellion a popular following a
genuine one. Finally that talented pay at Richard Waterhouse and Grice caskets.
Have depicted Bligh's setting himself against all the freedoms
and securities the opportunities in enterprise of a thriving commercial colony
and wanting it to take it back to the self-sufficient peasantry of the original plan.
If it does deal with blah's plans for Sydney he sees virtue in Bly conforming to Philip's plans
and nothing wrong in removing houses
when there was no good title to them it is true that townsfolk occupied their sites informally
or on a lease held at the will of a government but they might still have thought that they are home was their castle.
This does not occur if it.
He does not see that a governor declaring a house must be destroyed would seem as arbitrary as the astroid in
government declaring a person to be a communist some account as opposed to his wife.
That he preserve the liberties of the colony no longer seems as self-serving to us as it did to have it undoubtedly the
colonists convict's included.
Thought of themselves as possessing rights
and liberties which had nothing to do with the current form that the government of the colony took.
Just because there was a very powerful governor and just because there was no parliament
or a representative assembly that did not take everything else away the rule of law more
or less operated in New South Wales everyone charged before a court was innocent until proved guilty
and in the higher courts convictions coming from juries albeit compose for the moment of the offices.
Sadly this was not known to the designers of the monument to Magna Carta.
That was unveiled in Canberra in two thousand and one. One of the panels on the monument says this.
The early colonial settlements founded mostly by convict labor. Imposed this.
System of justice at odds with the rights and liberties expressed in Magna Carta.
This for a society where convicts could own property where they could defend it at law
and way they could not be punished further except by a rule of court by an order of a court.
The government was civil not military there was a time in the planning
when it was conceived as a military settlement with military law
but in the further development of the plan for New South Wales.
They moved the British government moved to a civil government for the colony the historians who have taken us through
that process and who have given us a new view of the colony at Botany by Alan frost and that concern. Andrew Tink.
From lighted to die. You of all labored inviting those words on the monument Cambra still stand.
And it would be a good thing if this anniversary led them to rethink and to remove them..
Geoffrey Blainey who first made his mark on the academic scene in the nine hundred sixty S.
Was an economic historian but by no means a Marxist he was not interested in the play of economic interests for years.
Strangely uninterested in politics and the state his interest is in the creation and effects of economic processes.
He is particularly interested in Vientiane
and technology in his first big book the rush that never ended published in nineteen sixty three he offered a new
interpretation of a style his other a billion that of the diggers at Ballarat in fifty four.
Blaney says that by eight hundred fifty four mining at Ballarat meant deep sinking not shallow holes
but shops of over one hundred feet deep
or as Blaney says with his homely hopeful comparisons as deep as in one thousand storey lift Well those shops took over
five months sometimes nine months to dig.
And still gold might not be found this deep sinking he believed was the key to understanding the armed rebellion of the
diggers at Ballarat in one hundred fifty four. Everywhere the collecting of license fees was an annoyance.
But it was infuriating on the deeply men had to come up from the depths to show their licenses
and licenses had to be paid for longer. Before it could be term and determined that the digging was worthwhile.
It was an attractive thesis
and it seemed to bring more depth to the account of the rebellion fifteen years later Western by published his history
of Ballarat which is called Lucky city his chapter on Eureka which I think is still the best thing on that subject
begins with the refutation of Blighty deep sinking since it began at Ballarat in one thousand fifty two had been
associated with peace and not with strife.
The largest protest against the license fee was at Bendigo in one hundred fifty three with the sinking.
We shall Ballarat stayed quiet while the Bendigo protest forced the government into a reduction in the amount of the
license fee bites account of Eureka invokes the traditional stories of license hunts the corruption of officials the
arrogance of the goldfield commissioners and the particular episodes that inflamed feelings about. Right.
Allowing Bentley the hotel proprietor to escape punishment for the murder of a minor called Skokie the harassing by the
police of the servant to the Catholic priest.
But this account is extended by highlighting how an English the administration of the goldfields was the heavy handed
collection of tax the magistrates not being independent gentleman J P's.
But the official commission is themselves who were hearing cases on their own licensing system.
By the way the licensing system which gave such a faints in Victoria began here in New South Wales
but here the fields were smaller and the commissioners more attuned to colonial ways
and not as in Victoria heiress to crack. Puppies. Fresh off the boat.
Bites account draws on and gives new credibility to the contemporary reports by the travellers William Howard
and William Calley who publish books on their experiences in a study in the icing fifty's with how what we hear the
diggers voices here is their response to the police dragging off a respectable storekeeper because they suspected his
horse was stone is this a Christian country. Asked one tick. Is this an English colony asked another no set of food.
It's Russia.
That's the comparison that how it drew himself not an English government
but a Russian despotism which a high spirited free born people could not accept the diggers protest sometimes broaden
into demands for the vote or for access to the land.
But what fueled the whole movement was the feeling that the goldfields administration in Thailand a denial of truth.
In all rights
and liberties during the Bendigo protest in one thousand nine hundred fifty three the tense of the diggers refusing to
pay the license carried the plaque I had no chimes for free Englishman a reference to the police China up offenders
and to look Court made.
Shades of the British government in the late eighteenth century deciding that they could not work convicts on China on
the roads because the public would not stand for.
So they had to go on looking for alternative places overseas which to send the condoms the accounts of the goldfields
by William Howard
and William Kelly were drawn on by Henry Handel Richardson for the opening section of her novel The fortunes of Richard
Manning like Howard himself Manny the well educated fastidious doctor is disgusted at Germans
and Americans thrusting themselves forward to lead the diggers protests
and wanting to give them an empty English Republican direction.
Manny takes the platform at a protest meeting but files to evoke enthusiasm for Britain's flag
and its generosity to foreigners. He's a gentleman. Telling the diggers what they should think.
But then his young friend. Purdie takes to the platform still with the mud clinging to his clothes.
Mommy now realizes why he didn't wash and challenge before coming to the meeting.
This is pretty speech which is an elaboration of one William Calley records in outline Richardson follows Kelly exactly
in the opening words brother diggers brother diggers. We are not made here to throw mud at our dear old country's flag.
Nor we have a word said against her most gracious majesty the queen not us.
We have we had men first and diggers afterwards we would not have a word said against her.
Against this gallant little woman.
Are you with me boys very well and now we didn't come here tonight to contact about getting votes
or having a hand in public affairs much as we want them both and mean to have them when the time comes.
No Tonight there's only one thing that matters to us
and that's the repeal of the a curse at Tex He has such an attempt at such a tempest of applause broke out that he was
unable to proceed. Yes I say it again. He went on when they would let him speak.
The instant repeal
when that's been done this cursed taken office then it will be time enough to parley voo about the color of the flag we
mean to have and about going shares in the government. But let me make one thing clear to you.
We're neither traitors to the Crown nor common rebels.
We're true blue Britons who have been goaded to rebellion by one of the violence pieces of tyranny that ever saw the
light.
Fighting against tyranny is part of our usual story about the God proved true blue Britons fighting against tyranny.
That's the element that's often forgotten. There is a strained attempt in popular history in schools and on T.V.
To link the diggers protest at Eureka to the coming of democracy
but no sustained democratic movement emerged from the diggings Victoria would have adopted manhood suffrage without you.
Rica just a South aside a New South Wales did Western by helps us to understand the lack of a sustained democratic
movement. Once the license and the gold through commissioners were swept away the basic loyalty and were.
Centeredness of the goldfields community reasserted itself. It was British again.
Ballarat did not become a hotbed of radicalism for tourism purposes now it might fly the rebel flag
but in the nineteenth century it was the most loyal of cities
when it finally arrested a memorial to the diggers who died at Eureka eating included the nym's of the dead soldiers as
well in the last couple of decades the historical profession has not been much interested in the gold fields
and democracy. It is the gold fields and racism that has come to center stage the N.T.
Chinese movement that began on the goldfields forms part of a study as sorry record as a rice nation which culminated
in the adoption of a Rice's national identity white astride racism is an evil but it is not a fixed and certain entity.
This is commonly not recognize commonly you are racist or you are not.
And once you are uncovered as a racist then your racism is as virulent
and we could as everyone else is the historian of rice ism cannot proceed in this way rises and grows
and declines that it might not disappear its strength faeries it take different.
It takes different forms and targets different objects.
It is subject to a variety of constraints personal and institution.
There are commentators who declare a Strider is still or ISIS nation.
There are undoubtedly still some racists and some racism here.
But a strike in racism cannot now be as strong as it was in ninety nine one
when immigration was totally prohibited astride
and racism cannot now be as strong as Germany's where into recently you.
To possess German blood to become a citizen
or strong as Japan's where its no immigration principle is only now being questioned comparisons are hopeful in taking
the measure of racism in nineteen seventy nine when the uncovering of racism in a strike this past.
Was just beginning and remarked has published a book comparing the treatment of the Chinese in California
and the struggle in the nineteenth century.
Marcus reports American dull gold diggers were accustomed to a racial hierarchy before they arrived in California they
knew whites were superior to negroes. So from the jump.
They treated the non white Chinese as inferior as to in Australia at first there was little hostility to the Chinese.
They were regarded as a civilised people. And there was a deal of curiosity about their customs.
But hadn't racism already got a firm hold in the Strider.
Because of the destruction of the Aborigines Marcus found that no one thought of Aborigines
and Chinese together as belonging to inferior races by nine hundred
when racism had got much stronger that link was mine
but not in the aging fifty's the hostility to the Chinese grew in the particular circumstances of the goldfields.
With the Chinese keeping themselves apart
and gold becoming harder to get in a struggle as distinct from California the rule of law extended to the Chinese they
were allowed to give evidence in court taking the oath in their own way in magistrates courts.
They were treated fairly in jury trials not so I worked on occasions not very often.
The European diggers drove the Chinese off the gold fields colonial officials in these cases worked to reinstate them
here the goldfield Commission has played
and heroic packed a temper Rouer the commissioner confronted an anti Chinese mob
and declared I would stand to be shot before I allow a Chinaman to be touched.
As a result of the digger's hostility the Chinese to the Chinese colonial government severely restricted the flow of
Chinese immigrants.
Once the borders were secure concerted moves against the Chinese on the Gulf fields ceased they lived on
and in the climbing numbers.
Most of them were going back to China at Bendigo they held
and on a place for they put on a parade with dragons every step as they still do.
Bendigo Ians neverless came with everyone else to believe in the water started a possum in a recent Ph D. Thesis.
Amanda rest mass and puzzles over the relationship between local
and national attitudes to the Chinese in Bendigo she tells of a certain councillor Caroline
and a striking born progressive reformer on the council.
Who wanted to clean up
and dignified Bendigo he called for the houses in the Chinese camps to be destroyed one group of these was not tucked
away. But at the end of the mine street. It looked like on occasions he might get is why.
But he never did the council stall. It asked for reports from police and health officials.
They found some unhealthy buildings but not too much worse than some low class European buildings. The smell.
Well so much complained of at the town camp came not from the Chinese the council itself turned out was responsible.
Behind the Chinese came it had located its horsemen you were Depor destroying houses is a serious step one of Carolyn's
opponents on the council to claim that the king himself had no power to interfere with the freehold
or resident titles hill by the Chinese side I remarked on this matter
and in other aspects of Bendigo his life rest mass
and finds that Europeans thought that the Chinese should have failed ply they were more likely to believe that because
not all the Chinese lived in the camps some lived among the rest of the population in similar houses
and were in regular work and our own businesses.
Fair play is an English term that comes from sport the English believe that sport was a preparation for life
and attitudes formed there should be applied to life generally English sport kind to ascribe it and with it.
The notion of fair play fair play is the origin of the a strident farrago even one of evidence speeches against the
Communist Party dissolution bill. He used fair ply fair go. And the principles of British justice interchangeably.
I've been demonstrating the strength of the appeal to British rights and liberties in a struggle.
And now I am pointing to a British origin of the a style unfair God.
This goes against the national nationalist tendency.
To see a style in society moving away from Britain and becoming more and more distinctive. Much better.
To see Britishness embedded within a stride.
Much better to think of British culture being re-interpreted in a struggle which is west and by its formulation
or better to read David Maloof wonderful essay on a style entire to. My in England but this is a message.
I don't have to underline to people prepared together in Sydney to celebrate the anniversary of the Magna Carta.
Thank you. THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU.
We don't have time for a few questions and John unfortunately is not going to be part of the panel was soft
and he has to return to Melbourne so this is your opportunity to put any particular questions to him
and I would ask that you keep the questions as brief of rate as possible so are there any questions or brief comments.
Yes the front. Join me on the platform. OK. There was.
Three years corpus cases in New South Wales about preventing Chinese people getting off their ships.
In the third case the Chief Justice in New South Wales and so annoyed by all of us because it was a legal.
He said that a man might even was sort of violent force to protect his liberty. So.
This underlies John's point of course that the more protective the Chinese even though it sometimes also of course
discriminated against. And this discriminate. It wasn't universal.
While the problem set sail for strategy which is where I live had to deal with was the pressure from Victorians to
impose restrictions on Chinese arrivals
and of course the long wonderful story quickly has been Chinese realise if they got off a boat from Victoria they had
to pay a tax. But they look at the map of Savile Strider said if we go to write and walk across the border.
We don't pay the tax. That was also a form of complying with the law. Thank you.
Years later on when some of the restrictions allowed Chinese who were British citizens. Still to come to a strike here.
The number of Chinese who claimed they came from Hong Kong. Went through the roof.
I think citing Japan as being moving away from Ras ism has a certain cultural Hakan many to.
In the sense that we practice very much a global concept of of the free flow of individuals the free flow of cultures.
I think Britain has been the recipient for a long period of Italian culture of Italian personnel of the movement
between continent and Island. To cite Japan as an example of a country moving away from prejudice and.
I think is incorrect. Categorically I think that Japan was isolated for a very long period in terms of moving people.
From Continental Shelf. Even though it had profound influences in terms of the history like Narron and period.
Their ideas are very much based on keeping cultural integrity.
And because of a profound love of the culture and a fear of it being eroded. I'd.
I don't regard this as complying with movements for global eyes ation
but I don't think a movement as such as you cited. Precious.
I think that if we go against the global movement it doesn't mean we're prejudiced I think that judgment.
Yet I have some sympathy for that viewpoint I think.
Racism is brought out now as a label for all sorts of things which strictly on rice isn't
and what you're suggesting is that. The word that's gone out of all the term that's gone out of use.
Now ethnocentrism might be a more accurate description.
But given the tendency to rises in which I think is you know almost universal. It's no centrism can move very easily.
Into Rice's And I'm not an expert on Japan. You seem to be so I'm out of unfairly libeled.
The Japanese It's interesting that the reason why there. There's some movement.
To reduce the hostility to immigration is because their population is declining.
I think astride a has a wonderful record in transforming itself from I want to strike the country to one of the most
open in the world. I mean the other reason for not thinking of a strike.
So as highly Reisa stories in a phobic is that of all nations on earth we have the highest proportion of people born
outside our country which promise I see seems to indicate that xenophobia and racism.
Can't be very strong but how do we make this transition. And the reason is you know because a start.
Is what particularly virtuous.
Well particularly racist the fright that the Japanese gave us in World War two was the argument that cole world used to
persuade astride ins that not that I would accept not what's But they would accept people who weren't British into a
struggle. So sometimes people. This was my point about things that constrain rices and.
You might have Rice's prejudice but they might be other reasons.
Like an aside this case of self defense which leads you to swallow down your prejudices a bit. And.
Be more open in the people you're willing to accept. Thank you. One more question.
And thank you very much for the talks this morning on this question period. As you indicated the principles.
Brought to us tires part of the English or British law.
However was the possibility that some of the principles that made account might be reflected in this community as an
astronomer prior to European settlement.
And if so much does principles be thought of as more universal as Mr Khouri suggested a basic human right.
I'm not an expert on that my first response would be to say no I don't think so because Aboriginal society in.
All aspects is closely involved in kin and obligation to kin.
So the notion of a universe Salah to that we are all citizens
or we are all subjects of the keen this is not going to such notions aren't going to operate in a hunter gatherer
society. Where your obligations are always specifically defined as being to particular persons.
So I don't think these general concepts of rights. Could emerge in Aboriginal society.